le djebel sarraut l'un des massifs les
plus reculés du sud marocain le coeur du
pays berbère
depuis l'aube ils sont des centaines à
s'être mise en route ils ont parcouru
parfois plus de 100 kilomètres sur des
pistes rocailleuses
tous sont descendants d'une des tribus
les plus renommés de la région les ait
atteint une fois par an c'est ici qu'ils
se retrouvent pour un moussem la fête
traditionnelle du sud marocain
said el ouarzazi lui est arrivé la
veille de marrakech j'ai grandi en ville
je suis d'origine berbère mais sa
première fois que je viens ici saïd à 22
ans il vient tout juste de terminer ses
études sa famille est originaire de ces
montagnes et pour lui ce moussem est un
véritable retour aux sources
comme tout ce qui arrive saïd doit
d'abord aller faire une fronde au sein
locale qui repose dans ce vieux mausolée
bonjour ça va bien merci
je voudrais savoir qui est ce ça et
comment il s'appelle son nom c'est sidi
saïd et sa tombe est ici c'est quand il
est enterré là depuis longtemps
il est ici depuis toujours nos parents
nos grands parents et même nos aïeux le
vénéraient déjà et comment on fait pour
lui rendre hommage à temps bien je vais
te montrer il faut passer la soul à
racines de l'arbre pour faire une
offrande je passe par où exactement
enlève du pnue shalev t bag ou sinon ses
péchés
dis donc c'est pas facile à faire un
nom et si tu veux que ton en france soit
valable il faut le faire trois fois
mais c'est trop petit mais non invasive
et les crocs comment ils font alors les
grands où ils payent plus cher
et l'offrande de la maison par la hat en
moi tu peux la déposer là
pourquoi des enfants l'emprise celui qui
se trouve là le droit de la page
l'amour c'est comme ça
merci beaucoup et que dieu nous vienne
en aide c'est ma
[Applaudissements]
la deuxième visite de saïd et pour le
vieil ali un des organisateurs du
moussem
comme tous les ait atta ali est fier de
ses origines et de sa tribu et comme
toujours en pays berbère l'hospitalité
et les histoires commencent avec un thé
à la menthe
c est une marque watts et un aït atta et
les aït atta s'était pas contribuer
c'est un ensemble il y en a au moins 25
je ne sais même pas qui pourrait te dire
ça aux gens
je ne suis qu'un gamin de 57 ans je ne
peux pas te raconter une histoire qui
dure depuis des milliers d'années le
mais ce que je peux te dire c'est que
les aït atta sont connus pour être des
guerriers
voilà ce qu'on sait faire chez nous
l'épée le fusil c'est ce qu'on a
et il y à aussi l'intégrité chez nous si
tu sors du droit chemin tu payes c'est
sûr
[Musique]
depuis la veille les bonimenteurs les
musiciens et les marchands ont investi
le village
c'est le dernier moussem la dernière
fête traditionnelle avant l'hiver pour
tous ici c'est la dernière occasion de
se procurer tout ce qui vient de la
ville
bientôt avec les pluies la neige et la
crue des rivières ces paysans et ces
nomades vont devoir vivre plusieurs mois
isolé dans les montagnes coupé du monde
[Applaudissements]
il est minuit la lune est pleine c'est
la dernière étape de la journée est la
plus attendue le ahidous la danse
traditionnelle berbère
la chorégraphie est extrêmement codifié
les hommes et les femmes dans ce face à
face en ligne et chante tour à tour
tout sourire tout mouvement un peu
appuyé est interdite
l'austérité est de rigueur pourtant dans
cette région où l'islam permet peu
d'écart le ahidous est perçu comme un
grand moment de liberté
pour les hommes c'est l'occasion de
pouvoir regarder les filles et de faire
peut-être la rencontre de celle qui
deviendra leur épouse pour les femmes
c'est l'occasion presque unique de se
faire remarquer
[Musique]
les femmes ne sortent jamais dans
l'homme dans leur maison et là c'est
l'occasion de sortir et que les hommes
waes puissent voir les femmes et les
formes aussi puissent voir les angles
les femmes qui sont descendus sur la
scène ça veut dire qu'ils ont pas du
mari alors ils sont près de recevoir à
mari et femme qui a un mari il peut pas
monter sur la scène parce que c'est
notre culture un petit peu et vous
est-ce que vous êtes venus pour
ce soir elles sont des dizaines à danser
leurs familles ont tout fait pour
qu'elle soit les plus belles nous
n'aurons pas le droit d'approcher de
discuter avec les plus jeunes c'est
fatima une veuve qui a été désigné pour
nous par les
voies légales est chez nous les femmes
doivent porter le foulard sur la tête le
drapé et la tunique c'est la tradition
oui c'est comme ça chez les berbères
si une fille et un garçon se plaisent le
garçon doit avant tout aller faire sa
demande auprès des parents de la fille
et avant il peut aussi se renseigner
auprès des gens qui connaissent la faim
moi j'ai rencontré ma femme non zaïdou
ce jeu les vues et elle m'a tout de
suite plu je suis allé demander sa main
à ses parents et ensuite on sais
marysthell
la danse durera toute la nuit et la nuit
suivante aussi comme chaque année des
garçons et des filles se rencontreront
un moussem c'est aussi ça le faire en
sorte que les descendants de la tribu se
marient et perpétue la longue lignée des
aït atta
le lendemain saïd quitte les montagnes
du djebel sarraut pour rejoindre la
vallée le berceau de sa famille le
village de nkok
c'est dans cette case back est né son
père brahim el ouarzazi homme d'affaires
est notable brahim et un aït atta fier
de ses origines
y ait cette kasbah la csc de mon arrière
grand père et maintenant il appartient à
mon oncle c'est la même chose c'est de
la famille de ce côté-là et de l'autre
côté et ainsi de suite
notre village est le plus peuplé en
casbah il ya quatre ans à 45 casbah les
premières ils ont déjà un siècle les
autres saisons plus de 60 ans dans le
temps il y avait des rivalités entre des
tribus et chaque tribu doit être forte
au point de vue casbah pour se défendre
et en même temps on doit à stocker nous
a d approvisionnement suffisant pour 2
ans minimum c'est dans cet esprit-là que
on leur a donné une architecture de
fortifications
mais aujourd'hui les fortifications de
nos clubs ont plus à craindre des
outrages du temps que des tribus adverse
alors pour sauver le patrimoine de son
village brahim a fait appel au savoir de
salima naji une architecte elle aussi
préoccupée par la fragilité de ces
trésors de paille de terre
voilà un exemple un exemple des maisons
abandonnées
une fois la casbah et abandonné il est
en train de se dégrader par la wii elle
va mourir
d'après les statistiques et les
dernières statistiques
à peu près dans les temps 2 % de la
population à quitter le village
c'est la nouvelle couche et enfin que de
se mettre en place actuellement
comme bonjour
get ready dont la prochaine fois il
faudra arroser le mur avant de mettre
ton m'ennuie parce que si tu ne mets pas
d'eau tombant de lui il ne tiendra pas
longtemps tu as compris
ça vous fait plaisir de voir les
méthodes traditionnelles en action bien
sûr surtout qu'il s'agit pas de quelque
chose de touristique mais de gens qui
n'ont pas refusé d'habiter dans le dans
le dans la terre et qui encore continue
à faire les enduits parce que l'hiver
arrive
on doit veiller à ce que la restauration
soit on pas mais dans les meilleurs
délais pour sauver votre patrimoine
architectural surtout dans des règles de
l'art
toutes les constructions du sud marocain
sont sont faites à partir de terre crue
mises dans des coffrages qui forment des
murs de pisé lemaitre pizer dame celle
qui frappe à la terre et à chaque coup
de pilon le pizer crient allah pour
honorer dieu car ici construire est un
acte sacré à la fin on a des murs
extrêmement solides qui vont pouvoir
durer franchir des années donc cette
solidité c'est que de toute façon même
avec des coups de bélier et même avec
extrêmement difficile de pénétrer à
l'intérieur
alors vous êtes les bienvenus dans la
casbah bas
pour donner l'exemple et encourager les
habitants d'une coque à restaurer leur
maison brahim el ouarzazi a entièrement
reconstruit sa propre casbah il ya six
ans c'est une casse ma qui a été
construite en 1945 par mon grand-père je
me souviens c'est là où j'ai passé mon
enfance
après la famille abandonnée là la casbah
pour moi à peu près 30 ans ce qu'elle a
exposés à bourg beaucoup de dégradations
il aura fallu cinq ans pour restaurer le
bâtiment car brahim n'employer que des
méthodes traditionnelles dans ses murs
pas un gramme de béton uniquement de la
terre et de la paille pour sauver la
casbah familiale brahimi a ouvert des
chambres d'hôtes pour accueillir les
voyageurs il a tout fait fabriquer dans
la région pour que l'artisanat local
continue à vivre vous voyez le lire et
complètement faire en codes
ses deux feuilles de palmiers et les
tapis le dans les chambres qui sont
confectionnés dans dans nos ateliers de
tissage on travaille avec tous les maths
il y eu deux
de la région et de et de l'eau c'est de
savoir faire de la région vous voyez
pour un avenant aux 6es de la poterie
ces voiliers voilà essai de d'assurer le
minimum de confort pour les gens qui
veulent vraiment vivre l'otan city et
l'authenticité n'est lui
même dans la cuisine aucune concession
n'a été faite à la modernité
ici rien n'a changé ou presque et les
visiteurs sont les bienvenues comme dans
tout le reste de la maison
ça fait plaisir de faire venir nous
inviter nos hôtes à avoir la préparation
du couscous les plateaux dans lesquels
on sert le couscous et
et d'autres choses vous les voyez ici
accrocher ce sont des plateaux en bois
il ya même des poteaux qui sont plus
âgés que moi sur comme celui là et les
très âgés et je me souviens très bien
j'ai mangé pas mal de fois du couscous
dans ce plateau en présence de mon grand
père est dans ma grand mère dans
ce qui est admirable et hors du commun
dans cette démarche c'est qu'il s'agit
pas simplement d'une belle demeure les
vraiment d'une démarche de l'intérieur
un grand respect de ce qui vient des
anciens et du et du patrimoine au sens
noble ce qui vient des pères et qui en
même temps se tourner vers l'avenir
qu'est ce que j'offre à mes enfants au
sens large aux gens du village pour
qu'il y ait un développement et un
développement intelligent
[Musique]
un développement qui a déjà permis aux
habitants de n'gog de maintenir vivante
leurs traditions
[Musique]
des traditions qui attire de plus en
plus les voyageurs désireux de sortir
des sentiers battus et de découvrir les
véritables trésors du pays berbère
[Musique]
ces trésors fragile du sud marocain
salima les a presque tous recensés
depuis dix ans elle sillonne la région
avec une solide et préserver l'identité
et la culture berbère
ce matin il nous emmène aux confins du
haut atlas sur le territoire d'une autre
grande tribu les high sound [ __ ]
elle tient à nous montrer de l'un des
joyaux de l'architecturé en pisé un
bâtiment encore jalousement entretenus
par les villageois un grenier collectif
aux allures de fortins
c'est un grenier qui se trouve sur la
partie la plus élevée du village sur une
partie où on peut voir toute la région
et être sûr que aucun attaquant arrive
et c'est en même temps un site qui
domine les airs à battre c'est là que
sont apportées à chaque récolte depuis
la vallée l'orge et qu on va vannes et
l'orge et qu'on montrera ensuite dans le
grenier les sacs
on mais aussi tous les titres de
propriété
les bijoux et le berbère a coutume de
dire c'est ma banque
grâce à salima les habitants acceptent
de les ouvrir les portes de leur coffre
fort normalement seuls les hommes du
village sont autorisés à rentrer ali aït
abdallah est l'un des plus gros fermé de
tâches dire
aujourd'hui il vient déposer sa récolte
ici chaque famille possède sa case
individuel il y en a 76 ans tout
un gardien désigné par la communauté
veille sur les biens des villageois
c'est la clé de la case
d'antiques serrure artisanale ferme les
portes de chaque grenier individuelle et
même si le temps des pillages et fini
les villageois continuent à venir ici
déposer leurs biens les plus précieux
ce matin le trésor dalli c'est sa
récolte d'or
mais avant de la mettre à l'abri il doit
la mesurer précisément car dans ces
montagnes arides la terre donne peu et
chaque saut de grains compte
avant d'entreposer dans le grenier si
elle est au mas va procéder au partage
adada
si ali procède si minutieusement à la
mesure de sa récolte c'est parce que
tout son grain n'est pas destiné à sa
réserve personnelle
est de 10
ça c'est pour la chose
la deuxième mesure est mise de côté pour
procéder à ce qu'on appelle des choses
c'est à dire l'un des devoirs de tout
musulman de données sur l'orge
entreposer de donner une part de ce
qu'il a récolté
la jour sera redistribué selon les
souhaits du propriétaire en général
l'offrande effet topo mais aussi aux
saints locaux à l'imam ou aux écoles
coraniques
si on fait des dons de cette sorte c'est
parce que ça existe depuis toujours et
qu'on continue à faire de même on le
fait pour allah pour qu'il nous donne de
la pluie et que les récoltes soit
fertile et les pauvres aussi ils ont
leur part oui c'est ce qu'on appelle la
chaux c'est ce qu'on a mis là bas pour
ceux qui n'ont rien
c'est pour ceux qui n'ont rien
mais le grenier collectif sert aussi de
place du village
c'est ici qu'après le travail des champs
à lier les autres hommes de la tribu se
retrouve
c'est ici aussi que se prennent les
grandes décisions que ceux discutés que
se décident les gestes de solidarité
on ne retrouve cela que dans ce
territoire berbérophones et que dans ces
montagnes où il fallait de toute façon
et protéger les biens et faire en sorte
d'aider sa communauté parce que on est
quand même dans un territoire de la soif
de la faim et de la dissidence
[Musique]
nous quittons les terres arides du haut
atlas pour rejoindre la vallée fertile
du drap à la découverte d'un mot
fortifier un ksar comme il en existe des
centaines dans le sud marocain le ksar
de table auquel
autrefois lexar est lé fief de caïds des
seigneurs locaux celui ci appartenait à
la famille des méritas
vraiment magnifique
salima retrouve mohamed un ami et un
habitant du ksar
[Applaudissements]
structure
ici nous sommes dans leurs phares de
thèmes nogal le retard le plus le plus
beau de
draps et au fond ce sûr que ça comme on
le voit et herstal
dessiné pour pour accueillir des chevaux
pour pour la fête pour la noblesse il
s'agit du rck soeur d'aimé s'git à cette
famille qui y avait quand même une très
grande puissance locale
depuis les caïds ont perdu leur pouvoir
et leur fortune mais l'héritier des
méritas vit toujours dans le ksar avec
sa famille il habite derrière cette
porte vieille de plus de 500 ans c'est
ici que vivait son grand père ali le
dernier caïd de tam nobel
saïd nous entraîne dans un dédale de
couloirs et de cours à la découverte du
palais de sa famille
en tout six maisons construites au cours
des quatre siècles qu'a duré le règne
des méritas
il faut imaginer une faste qui pourrait
y avoir dans cette maison qui était une
maison princière le nombre d'esclaves
qui pouvait y avoir un peu partout et
puis évidemment le bruit et les
constantes allées et venues entre leurs
caïds et ces sujets
a dit cissé la demeure du caïd mohamed
lors des 31 cas il mourrait un autre le
remplace et il fallait qu'ils
s'installent avec toute sa cour donc il
faisait construire une nouvelle demeure
on a ici un des plus beaux patio du sud
l'artisan a su là encore mêlé un
vocabulaire architectural appartenant à
l'art arabo andalouse et en même temps
des choses tout à fait le dis si on le
voit notamment dans le détail de ces
plafonds temps deviner par toutes les
volutes qui sont les arabesques qui sont
utilisés les couleurs aussi les rosaces
tout le travail de composition
extrêmement fleuret en même temps très
africain ça rappelle même des choses
d'ethiopie par moment il ya une identité
propre à un artisan ra territoire
malheureusement les héritiers du caïd
n'ont plus aujourd'hui les moyens de
préserver comme il le faudrait leur
patrimoine
le vieux saïd a dû faire des choix avec
son salaire de fonctionnaire à la mairie
de tarnos galt il s'est concentré sur
l'entretien d'une seule des six maisons
du palais
c'est ici qu'il s'est installé avec la
trentaine de membres de sa famille
nous avons dû insister pour qu'il nous
ouvre les portes de sa demeure car said
el kaïd affiche une certaine pudeur face
à la pauvreté dans laquelle sont tombés
les héritiers des méritas
ici c'est une chambre
[Musique]
si je n'habitais plus ici tout ça
pourrait disparaître
moi tous les matins je fais le tour de
la maison et je regarde si quelque chose
ne va pas mais le mot tabarre qu'avec ce
genre de construction situe tarder à
réparer elle décide ça peut se dégrader
très vite
et ensuite ça coûtera encore plus cher
pas question donc pour saïd d'abandonner
la demeure de ses ancêtres il ne sait
que trop bien le sort qu'elle subirait
pour nous aider à le comprendre il nous
emmène voir l'ancien quartier juif voilà
ça c'est le mellah le quartier juif ou
plutôt ce qu'il en reste depuis que
toute la communauté est parti pour
israël il y à 40 ans
mais il n'ya pas que le quartier juif
qui tombe en ruine à table nous gate des
dizaines de casbah s'écroule abandonnés
par des propriétaires
attirés par le confort et la modernité
certains ont rejoint les grandes villes
où sont partis à l'étranger d'autres se
sont installés tout près juste derrière
les remparts dans un village de maisons
en béton seule une dizaine de familles
continuent à vivre dans look ça
s'écroulait s'effondraient les espaces
correspondait à des vies avec des
familles élargies et donc ce lieu
correspondait tout à fait à ce à quoi
enfin aux attentes des gens qui
l'habitent est aujourd'hui celle inverse
argent maintenant ils cherchent
l'indépendance et cherche de vivre
seulement avec leur famille pas avec
leurs frères et l'aurait leurs parents
vont comme avant
[Musique]
avec les casbahs c'est aussi toute une
série de métiers artisanaux qui
disparaissent
déjà les maîtres pizer se font rares
vaincu par le béton
salima nous emmène voir l'un des
derniers artisans à maîtriser le boom
rick l'art de la porte berbère il
s'appelle m'bark heitz bach et
[Musique]
ses portes sculptées son réputé dans
toute la région elle décore les villas
de nombreuses personnalités de marrakech
et sont de plus en plus recherchée à
l'étranger
je ne sais pas écrire je n'ai pas fait
d'études mais ce que j'ai vu avec mes
yeux je saurai le réaliser avec mes
mains et ma mémoire ne me joue jamais de
tours
rabaud et fasse moi ça
tout l'art du boom rick repose sur la
précision et la symétrie barque n'hésite
jamais à recommencer si le travail n'est
pas parfait
il ya quelque chose qui va pas
ça me plaît pas c'est tout
autour de cet ouvrage trois générations
sont au travail pourtant le carnet de
commandes est loin d'être remplis et les
deux fils de m'bark survivre grâce à des
travaux beaucoup plus ordinaire
vous faites souvent ce genre de travail
ça arrive de temps en temps seulement de
temps en temps une ou deux fois par an
pas plus
les gens l'apprécient plus ce genre
d'art tri-zone or
quand tu leur parles de beaumerie qui
savent même plus que ça veut dire
maintenant ce qu'ils veulent c'est des
placards les tables des armoires tout ça
aujourd'hui les gens veulent du moderne
personne ici n'achèterait ça pour le
maître chez lui à part certains
touristes qui le ramène chez eux
ce travail requiert du temps
de la rigueur est finalement un très
long apprentissage mais c'est des choses
qui se font de moins en moins on ne veut
pas payer les gens à leur juste valeur
et on méprise le travail manuel donc
c'est des formes c'était savoir faire
qui ne peuvent être pérennisée
il faudra trois jours à toute la famille
pour terminer cette porte probablement
l'une des dernières pour le vieux maître
à 86 ans il a transmis tous ses secrets
et c'est que son savoir faire est entre
de bonnes mains celles de ses propres
fils à condition qu'ils acceptent de
prendre le relais les mavs si l'un d'eux
ne veut plus faire ce travail c'est plus
mon fils celui qui refuse de faire le
métier de son père ne mérite plus d'être
son fils
comme la famille m'bark de plus en plus
d'habitants du sud marocain ont pris
conscience de la richesse de leur
patrimoine et de leurs traditions un
patrimoine fragile à l'image de ces
casbah de terre qui chaque jour avec la
régularité d'un sablier grain par grain
s'effrite un peu plus si quelques-unes
ont retrouvé une partie de leur
splendeur grâce au travail des
restaurateurs pour beaucoup d'autres
malheureusement il est déjà trop tard
[Musique]